[Musique]
en situation de crise comme maintenant
des arnaqueurs de toutes sortes temps
évidemment d'en profiter à nos dépens
mais certains camps sont un peu
différents prenez par exemple le cas de
cette publication virale dans laquelle
on dit que le gouvernement fédéral offre
une indemnité de confinement de 756 $ et
invite ainsi des gens cliquer sur un
lien pour en faire la demande
comme leur rapidement constaté mon
collègue et nicolas de rosa
cette prime n'existe tout simplement pas
et contrairement aux informations
véhiculées dans certains médias
québécois
le lien qui accompagne la publication
n'est pas malveillant d'abord la
véritable aide fédérale fait en ce
moment se nomme en fait de prestations
canadiennes d'urgence et prévoit le
versement de 2000 dollars par mois aux
personnes qui ont perdu leur emploi en
raison d'un colis de 19 si vous avez
perdu votre emploi que vous travaillez à
temps plein ou à contrat où que vous
soyez travailleurs autonomes
cette prestation est là pour vous sachez
d'ailleurs que les canadiens peuvent
faire la demande pour cette aide
d'urgence en ligne ou encore aussi par
téléphone mais pour en revenir à la
publication initiale plusieurs personnes
nous ont écrit en se questionnant sur
les dangers encourus si jamais on répond
ce qu'on a constaté c'est que si ces
personnes avaient cliqué sur le lien qui
accompagne la publication elle se serait
vite rendu compte qu'il s'agit avant
tout d'une blague ce lien mène en fait
vers une image d'un gorille et pour
faire un doigt d'honneur
si vous avez vu cette publication et
n'avait pas cliquer sur le lien suggéré
vous avez bien fait pour prévenir les
fraudes
il est recommandé de ne jamais cliquer
sur des liens de sources inconnues
officiel je vous suggère de consulter
l'article de nicolas de rosa à ce sujet
sur notre page web la page web des
décrypteurs n'hésitez pas à nous écrire
aussi par courriel si vous avez des
doutes sur des choses qui circulent sur
le web
et n'oubliez pas derrière notre groupe
facebook il ya déjà plus de temps mais
les personnes qui n'ont fait allez salut
[Musique]